[Music]
cs:go is a game played in split-second
bursts rounds often come down to the
final bullet it all comes down to or a
last-second defuse and when you find
yourself in that situation and your team
comes out on top well sometimes there's
only one thing left to say now guys it
is it's all about the hardcore intense
situations either there is humor that
comes with the inevitable downtime
between rounds during pauses or even
during warmup that's right
this week on Vesta we're listening in on
the very best of csgo pro player comms
already up the clinics
[Music]
you want to open who gives a [ __ ] with
riches [ __ ]
okay zero to Poona we need today to be
base and it just won't be okay
don't not from beginning but like hotel
deficit start to say no I know I know
they have smoke again 22nd
[Music]
come on let's [ __ ] do this right here
JW smiley on Disko JW smiling at me
my hands are sweaty guys remember
Ricky's call when the guy was boosted in
NZ on train against King surprise I was
in the video let's go [ __ ] let's go
[ __ ] we are not giving up this game
let's [ __ ] them yes let's go there till
they are till tip-off I got a boner
Oh what they're actually decoding tease
me what did you say your is itching
that's [ __ ] ever been shown the storm
and we're standing still for a second we
have to show some balls
yeah sure you show me above man I can do
it later
musashi occasion
hey boys nice freakin a reporter kilos
rule should I remember Tina Fey just
like this as acute against the last week
puts the other one I'm afraid to drink
anything it's only for the commercials
or can you actually it's fine hearing
the crowd roar after an incredible play
he's like icing on a clutch cake now
hearing player calms after an incredible
play is like sweeter icing on a bigger
cake
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh City smokin his search and I think
you know that they need a bump one to go
into the next round with too much so
he's gonna at least grant than that but
now he knows himself below and the so
much damage leaves him on to just eight
HP and is giving himself a real chance
here pushing together
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
actually find a second you should know
that AZ is around in the pit pop flash
comes out leaves it another one he's
only on to one HP but he's given himself
a chance the dog I need the flames but
it doesn't actually go it doesn't go off
that could be the biggest problem of
POVs lice he's a boss but nothing's
gonna be spotted and it's you know guys
the English language is one of the most
complex and nuanced in the world we've
got about half a dozen different words
for any situation you may find yourself
in in life but after a particularly
dominant duel or a nasty flick there's
really just one word you want to say
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
nice oh my god that shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
well guys that's all we got for you this
week on best of go ahead and hit that
subscribe button and if you already did
well I got one word for you
nice nice
we try the other version cool